I'm a developing story today British
gymnastics naming coaches who have been
banned this is as part of a response to
an investigation exposing the Sport's
abusive culture it follows a review
which found that young gymnasts in
Britain had been left humiliated shamed
and permanently psychologically or
physically damaged with our Sports
correspondent Rob Harris joins me now
with more on this um and Rob this is in
reaction to that review as I said
the the action that's leaping out is
naming and shaming coaches but there's a
40-point action plan from this can you
give us some more measures that is going
to transform as it's build British
gymnastics
yeah the hope is it does transform
British gymnastics for the better and
that that the welfare of athletes is
improved and particularly that this
Focus that might have been there
perceived in the past of medals over the
well-being of athletes is reversed and
it's all about the well-being of future
Olympians potentially future Olympians
who are training here at lilishal the
British gymnastics HQ and it's here
today we've been hearing the reform 25
plan it's the 40-point agenda to try to
improve welfare in the sport and at the
heart of it is this plan to name coaches
who have been banned and we've been
hearing more from the chief executive of
British gymnastics explaining how this
will work
one of the elements around say sport is
making sure that we have processes and
policies in place and if we are made
aware of an investigation then we will
determine of whether a child is at risk
if a child is at risk and that person
will be suspended and removed from that
environment if that child is not deemed
to be at risk then they will be able to
continue to coach the key thing here is
that we are really clear about the
standards that we expect for all of our
coaches and the environments we want to
see that they are safe they are
supportive and they are positive for all
involved
the issue is that not all coaches will
be banned for life and once their ban
has been served they will be removed
from this database so you could have
guardians of children who are entering a
sport and being coached by someone who
might have previously served a ban but
no one will know about it also coaches
who are suspended their names won't be
published so someone could still be
involved in the sport perhaps in another
country even or indeed another sport
without that being known so there are
some gaps within this plan although it
is a plan that is aimed to actually try
to ensure there is a better environment
and it's something that particularly
gymnasts who have been survivors of
abuse have been calling for
what's not included in this document is
is details of the very num the high
numbers of cases of eating disorder uh
life-limiting injuries there's there's
nothing in there which represents the
kind of calls that I get on a weekly
basis from gymnasts and parents across
the country who continue to suffer or
are suffering in gyms
um and I think that that represents a
quite a big gap in the reform document
well British gymnastics are saying there
will be a zero tolerance approach
they're also saying that there needs to
be a cultural understanding that the
fear created has no place in gymnastics
but this is called reform 25 the aim is
to introduce all these changes by 2025
that's three years away a year after the
Paris Olympics and the hope is from
particularly former gymnasts those
involved in the sport is that the pace
of change is accelerated